die neuartige zaubert hat die serie k -o
-runde das feld meinung der neue film
von aktivität von dem schauspieler
ehepaar was allabendlich in arthur
millers tod eines handlungsreisenden
weibliche männliche hauptrolle outfit
und dann wörtern die frau eines
nachmittags überfall
wir sehen nicht von wem wir haben nur
sozusagen dadurch eine ahnung dass wir
wissen diese wohnung hat einer
prostituierten gehört die viele
männerbekanntschaften hatte und ist
diese frau im kaffeehäusle kopfverband
nicht mehr ansprechbar wendet sich von
ihren landab wenig darüber reden will
auch keine anzeige
die strecke kann die tür aufgemacht ist
die beziehung zwischen diesen beiden
menschen die ganz langsam in die größe
ist gar nicht nach der mann er liegt
sechs ich würde anzeige machen und du
lässt mich nicht gesucht nachdem straßen
er hat glück denn der täter hat sein
auto sogar gelassen
ein auto hat meine frau anschauen es war
ein transporter wenn ich dir das kann
zwischen gebe
und du sagst jetzt in meinem vater
gehörte freundlich sind für mich die
adresse herauszufinden
er hat noch freunde bei der behörde wenn
sie mir das kennzeichen geben bringe ich
ihnen die adresse wir erleben ein
menschliches drama in alberne ambivalent
und können wir nicht wirklich etwas
kennen
abhilfe kann man die leistung gesteigert
wird dieser trend fort dann wählt man
hier kennt die geschichte der deutliche
merkmale erleben die gleichzeitig
künstlerisch gefahren wird ist filmisch
auf freitag exakt genau nicht
ich war spricht angesichts des umfangs
ist dieser film immer noch hoch zu
empfehlen und bewerten was gelangt
keine sorge patrick eines schönen tages
werden wir uns wiedersehen
[Musik]